hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel i'm back with an answer to
one of the most frequently asked
questions i've gotten about the galaxy
nexus since i got it and that's been
about the camera on the back it's gotten
very mixed reviews i even gave it a
mixed review in my first impressions
video by the way thumbs up on this video
um but i just want to preview this video
by saying that you know there are 3
megapixel sensors there are 5 megapixel
sensors there are 8 10 and 12 megapixel
sensors all in smartphones but it's
really all about the quality of the
optics which is basically the sensor and
the glass
and i'll go more into this in the video
but i basically want to let you guys
know this is my review of the camera of
the samsung galaxy nexus it's really all
about anything you could possibly want
to know about it so uh sit back relax
and enjoy here we go
so as we've all heard the galaxy nexus
has a 5 megapixel rear facing shooter i
like saying shooter instead of camera um
but it has a 5 megapixel shooter and it
has a single led flash which does a
great job for illumination especially
during video i found that dual led was
actually a little bit too bright so it's
a 5 megapixel back facing shooter and a
single led flash so let's get right to
the test shots because i know that's
what you guys probably came here to see
so we started off indoors and this is a
look at the camera software and one of
the most important things about the
software is number one tap to focus and
number two instant shutter so as soon as
you take a picture uh whether or not
it's in focus or not you can choose
whether or not to focus bam the pictures
taken no lag whatsoever i'll show you
some of these pictures and some videos
in a second but basically the gallery is
just like any other version of android
so it's nothing really too noteworthy
here so let's go ahead and jump back out
and look at the video mode video mode
with the 5 megapixel sensor you can take
720p videos or you can take 1080p videos
you can also take standard definition
but i chose for 720p just so it would
match up nicely and the frame rate is 30
frames per second so you can see here it
does look pretty good this is all
indoors of course you have the crazy
special effects no one will use and the
time lapse mode and other cool options
and stuff but overall it's about the
quality right
yeah yeah that's right
so let's just go ahead and start
recording and as you can see here we are
still indoors and it doesn't look all
that bad but like i said it's it's from
a cell phone so this is really
acceptable so here's some more video
that i took indoors and again not all
that bad looking but not all that sharp
either it could be a little bit sharper
but i do appreciate that i can take a
video in low light but just remember
that in low light auto focus like any
other camera will take a little bit
longer so now let's take it outdoors
where this actually really shines i
walked around in 25 degree weather
that's fahrenheit not to get these shots
for you and from what i can see it looks
around average you know nothing too
spectacular this is 720p it definitely
works the frame rate is easily 30 frames
per second so i'm gonna say on the
smartphone scale this guy takes around
an eight for me i definitely would use
this to take video and send it to people
zooming in and out though while
recording is just something you don't
want to do it's just a tip the
front-facing camera on the galaxy nexus
which is footage that you're looking at
right now is also 720p and it looks
pretty good to be honest it also has
facial tracking so if i move my head
around it's constantly focused on my
face so uh that's a pretty good feature
and
i'm a fan so definitely going to be
using this for like google chat and
skype and things like that now taking a
look at the pictures it takes these are
where it's literally hit or miss if you
press the shutter button when the item
is out of focus you will get that out of
focus picture so i always tap to focus
just to make sure and i got pretty
average results again nothing to write
home about but the convenience factor of
having instant access from the lock
screen and instant shutter really does
make up for it in my opinion and uh i'm
really a big fan of the camera software
rather than the camera hardware
so that's it for you guys that's
basically my overview of the galaxy
nexus it's probably going to be my last
video until i can really get to know
this phone and give you guys my full
review but expect some other tech videos
and some other youtube tips coming up in
the very near future thanks for watching
and i'll talk to you guys later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you